[Music]
as Robin said I am a trained and have
been operating for about the last 25
years as a social psychologist and
experimental social psychologist and
it's been only in the last couple of
years that I have moved much more to
community-based research in order to be
able to move the research to having an
impact so what I'm talking to you about
is are some of the lessons that I've
learned in part in hopes that you
understand when you reach into academia
to try and take advantage of the rich
expertise that exists there there is a
patience required as we go through each
of us goes through this kind of a
learning process so I I do do research
on discrimination and its impact on
marginalized groups including the
well-being of members of marginalized
groups and the collective resilience in
terms of overcoming some of the negative
effects of discrimination in the past 10
years we moved to looking at the effects
of the Indian Residential schools on the
offspring of survivors primarily through
the use of national surveys that
research provided us with a large
quantitative database that allowed us to
understand some of the mechanisms that
were associated with the greater
depressive symptoms anxiety trauma
symptoms of offspring of both of
survivors both the parents and
grandparents who had encountered or
experienced the Indian Residential
schools it also allowed us to understand
some of the mechanisms our early life
experiences stress of proliferation as
adults how identity disruption all
contributed to some of the
symptomatology and to start looking for
resilience factors in this area having
quantitative data
was was actually extremely important and
our work started to come to the
attention of for example the aboriginal
healing foundation which has since been
closed but they became very supportive
of our work and brought us in to conduct
a number of other studies including a
study on the student-to-student abuse
that had occurred in the Indian
Residential schools and what the
implications of that were for continued
lateral violence within some of these
communities not surprisingly this was an
extremely sensitive issue for many
Aboriginal communities and their
survivors and so when the book was
launched we held a blessing ceremony in
Sioux look at the site of the Indian
Residential school at Pelican Falls in
order to be able to to launch this with
sensitivity and with an honoring of the
survivors and this was the beginning of
our work in the community of Sioux
Lookout one of the members of the
Advisory Board of the healing foundation
was garnet and is garnet and to Kanab
and he encouraged us following this
ceremony to take the work that we had
been doing to try to make a difference
to make lives better for the survivors
of the Indian Residential schools he's
been a strong advocate for their
survivors and certainly someone who has
been pushing very strongly for this to
be part of the Canadian dialogue and
part of the Canadian psyche he has been
our champion he is a he is a residents
of the Sioux Lookout area and he is a
member of the Lac Sol First Nation he
has been incredibly supportive of us and
as we start to try to build
relationships in the area and to help us
not to step in on to too many landmines
that champion within the community I
think is central to our ability to work
with the community but it wasn't just a
champion that launched us into working
with this in this area and to moving
towards a community-based approach
around the same time so last summer in
June and see
Farah was part of supporting this we
held own a conference where we brought
people from across Canada to talk about
Aboriginal identity and how these
included practitioners researchers
students academics and and this provided
us it wasn't the first time people had
talked about Aboriginal health of course
and many of the members of the audience
and the speakers knew each other but for
us it provided us with the relationship
with that community of practice that
also meant that we were able to rely on
a foundation of support as we moved
forward our keynote speaker was James
Barr tlemen who was the lieutenant
governor of Ontario and if any of you
have ever heard him speak about the
suicides in First Nations communities in
Northern Ontario and the importance of
education and the call the plea for
something to be done about this issue
then I don't think any of you could have
left the room with a dry eye and not
felt motivated to do something and
finally around the same time again so
this was a number of factors transpired
to move us very quickly into working
with community of the community there
were funding calls that made it possible
for us to potentially get the funding to
do this work can you community-based
research as many of you will know should
not start with people trying to get
funding and I think many of you have
probably experienced academics calling
you up and saying could we include your
name on our funding application because
then it will be successful and then you
never hear from them again and we were
very aware that this happens at the same
time these funding opportunities provide
a basis for focusing a relationship that
that people can figure out where we're
trying to get to and build a vision and
it also creates some sense that there is
a possibility of actually implementing
implementing something if the funding
comes through once you've started that
relationship building however there's no
turning back and we are still looking at
many funding opportunities even though
the first one that we worked on with
this community wasn't successful we have
so many others out there now that that
you can't just drop the community and
say oh sorry didn't work see you later
so what is the project that we've been
working on that's way too fast for
myself you I know I have 15 minutes
we're working with the the region of
Sioux Lookout the Sioux Lookout health
where our primary partner the Sioux
Lookout First Nations Health Authority
catchment region and our focus is on
youth suicide but not directly and not
from a clinical interventionist
perspective the suicide rates in this
region are 50 times five zero times
higher than the general population in
Canada one community in particular
pecans acum has among the highest rates
in the world of suicide it is it is what
some would call a crisis within the
region we're working together with
community organizations in the region to
explore strategies for building youth
resilience and creating community
conditions to foster a good life for the
youth our goal is to take a holistic
perspective to intervention that's
multidisciplinary multi-sector and
community led and recognizes that this
issue occurs within a context all of the
communities in this region have been
affected by the Indian Residential
schools they are all contending with
issues of collective and historical
trauma of continued systemic
discrimination and associated with the
legacy and continued implementation of
the Indian Act that's resulted in in
poverty inadequate community
infrastructure health and equities
disadvantages in education over
representation of the children in the
child welfare system and over
representation of youth in the justice
system there are many organizations
working in the region we're not the
first but the problems continue to exist
and not because people aren't
thoroughly doing the right thing but
because there is very little
coordination across a region of
primarily flying excuse-me communities
funding runs out there are
jurisdictional issues that occur there
in equities across bands and band
councils and there's sometimes a lack of
evidence backing some of the programs
that are being implemented within the
communities so we've been working in
this region for now and building the
partnership for almost two years we have
an idea based in evidence of the kind of
project that would actually maybe make a
difference so we walk in and we had an
idea based on the research that a number
of our partners who are contributing to
this we have a fairly large team of
about 30 researchers and practitioners
working with us from various
organizations across Canada now and we
thought okay one of the the areas that
we that many of our researchers have
found has been very effective and
particularly working with youth is to do
digital storytelling digital
storytelling allows them to get engaged
in a medium that they're very
comfortable with it allows them to get a
better understanding of their roots of
where their culture has come from and to
understand their traditions it can be
used to connect them with elders and
adults within the community and to
connect them with each other and to
think about an envision a future for
themselves we thought this was a great
idea we talked to youth about it they
loved the idea many of the community
organizations also really liked it but
it's an idea that has to wait for
funding because we don't have the
equipment and we don't have the
resources to actually implement it does
that mean we have to wait until we
actually get funding that's not a great
idea to walk away from the community
because then you lose a lot of the
momentum and the credibility with the
community about your seriousness so
sometimes you just look at what's
already been happening and one of our
experiences was to talk to one of the
deputy grand Chiefs of the region who
basically when we walked in to talk to
him said we don't need you we're already
doing many
and we don't need someone from Ottawa
some white woman from Ottawa coming up
and telling us how to be Indian and then
he talked to me all about a project that
he has been championing within the
region called embrace life I hadn't
encountered brace life embrace life
before they had an event in February of
this year and so I and a couple of my
colleagues decided to fly up to Thunder
Bay to join the embrace land life event
I have never before been to a
fundamentalist revivalist meeting which
is exactly what this was it was intended
to bring families together with with
with the Lord to become stronger and to
work through the grieving process
associated with the losses that they'd
encountered it was complete with gospel
singers brought up from the south and
the u.s. it was it was insightful it was
a learning experience as a researcher
when we're not there to judge it wasn't
necessarily something that we could
relate to but our job there was to learn
to understand a whole segment of the
community up there Christianity is a
huge part of the communities in
northwestern Ontario and to begin to
figure out how we could actually work
within that context there are other
projects though that we could actually
jump into so one of the public schools
what has launched is in the process
actually of launching a hockey academy
hockey is also big up there the school
had already put in a foreign application
for accreditation with Hockey Canada
they have equipment that's been donated
to them from jumpstart and our role is
to work with that school to actually
evaluate the potential impacts of this
program on the well-being of the
children so we have a rule to play
they're jumping on an initiative that
was already started by the community so
basically one of our first learning
lessons was that you don't walk in with
a project predefined that there is a
need to be flexible sometimes to stand
back and just watch sometimes to jump in
where they might have something to
contribute to an ongoing initiative but
sometimes to also bring an expertise
that might not
already exists there and apply that in
conjunction with the other kinds of
events that are ongoing okay so we have
to be a flexible in the nature of the
project we also have to be flexible in
terms of understanding who is the
community so the tri-council chapter 9
actually refers to working with
aboriginal communities and we're
supposed to consult and work with the
community to define the directions for
it what does this mean we know that
there is a very strong Christian element
within almost every single community in
the region and that stands beside a very
strong traditional element in some of
these communities even the elders are
separated you have the elders who are
Christian living in one area the
community and the elders who are
traditional living in another area of
the community sometimes they work well
together and sometimes it's extremely
divided you can't just look at the
symbols that would tell you because the
one community where a hundred percent of
the community speaks is the native
language is actually one of the most
Christian communities in the region yes
you have to work with the the Chiefs and
band councils you can't work with the
community without the permission of the
chief and band councils but how
representative are they of the community
how representative are they of the
marginalized elements of the community
some of the people who are experienced
homelessness violence within the home
they've experienced child abuse are they
actually being represented by the Chiefs
and how do you actually access them to
talk about these issues within community
the children have a voice we're looking
at youth resilience we have to talk with
the children that's not always
compatible with the views of the elders
the communities have very different
issues some of them in this region are
part of the Ring of Fire and they're
very concerned about the economic
development some are dealing with water
boil advisories for the last 10 years
some of them are living in very crowded
conditions who is the community
we have expectations of engagement so we
put together a whole group of
organizations that would work with us
and we start implementing oops one of
them has moved to another project
another one has moved to another
organization altogether one of them lost
his job and so is still working with us
but the organisation's not then there
anymore oh but we do bring on others
that this is a team sport so you have to
keep bringing on organizations to work
with you then we had a whole
organization leave us because their
funding ran out and so they couldn't put
us as their priority there is an
election so our Chiefs we had to start
again in terms of our relationship
building there you get the idea some
organizations are more stable and they
become central to the partnership they
become central sometimes because they
they are totally aligned with the values
that you represent okay so many
organizations are resourced strapped
they're looking for the mule power that
we can provide often with our grant
funding we download a lot of work on to
community organizations where full time
researchers community organizations are
not and I'm sure you understand that we
often leave you with our students to be
able to fill in that that working work
power but students are also work
somebody has to oversee them somebody
has to make sure they're busy all day
somebody supervising finding them with
the desk to work at a computer to work
at making sure that they don't go out
and make mistakes with very vulnerable
populations so they are there are
excellent experiences you can have with
students but they are not the answer I'm
going to just quickly say that there are
issues around data who does it belong to
whoops I'll go back one second when you
get stories from community members as it
their story or the community story the
First Nations are overseen by Oh cap
which I don't think every community has
that helps us helps guide us through
that there are issues around
accessibility of data and there are
issues around how the data is used often
community organisations are looking for
the day
for advocacy as researchers we often are
motivated by that need for advocacy but
we have to remember what our
contribution is is the evidence that
forms the basis of the advocacy we are
not the advocates and that compromises
the data when we start seeing ourselves
as the advocates why do we do it we do
it not for a lot of bad reasons we do it
primarily because we are interested in
becoming part of a process of working
with communities we're not trying to
test our own dear ideas and to publish
necessarily what we're trying to do is
be part of a system that can make a
difference that we can actually in our
hearts and souls find ways of taking
what we know as experts in our fields
and making a difference in the
communities so thank you I got to leave
this and not walk off with it I'm sure
people in the room are incredibly struck
and I was when we chatted in advance of
this by the thoughtfulness of the
approach clearly your commitment to the
youth and the communities but also the
the adaptability and how you have gone
about doing your work so I think those
are themes that out that I will hear
again and thank you for that
so Axl's gonna come up I think what
we'll do is let's let's have axel
present and then pause for a minute we
can take questions on a couple unless
there's any any immediate questions
we'll have time at the end but but I did
promise we'd have time in between so
actually if there's questions we may
just pause for one second yeah go ahead
let's take a minute or two and if you've
got a question for Kim let's start with
one or two now and come back more
I think who sticks their suit yeah and
you're just digital what these days is
in fun or do I need to do some very much
for your incredible presentation at the
PowerPoint was just beautiful the images
we're really compelling one thing I'm
grappling with is social innovation I
don't see social innovation anywhere
except on the hashtag of this event and
that term social innovation I know it
could change maybe you have a great
definition I don't have it at hand do
you see yourself as a social innovator
okay I think that if you don't walk into
these communities thinking in terms of
social innovation that you're making a
big mistake that's when we start walking
in with preconceived ideas of exactly
what has to happen and even if we have
those preconceived ideas they have to be
adapted it may not be transformational
innovation it's much more likely to be
incremental innovation but at the same
time what you're taking our programs
ideas an evidence base and your you have
to transform it to meet the needs of
particular communities we had no idea
that we were walking into a highly
Christianized environment what does that
do in terms of the ideas okay we're
gonna bring you know drumming and
smudging and I'll forget it you know you
have to really think differently so I
don't think we could walk into this
community without being having a social
innovation mindset I named Jayden
edition ACCA's as a researcher who was
just up in the region and who does work
in the region hmm
I guess I do have a couple questions so
I would like to talk to you later but
the question I would ask now is I was
just with some of the youth up in Dryden
and you know one of the things that they
talked about was when a person of
authority comes into our community or
comes into our schools it's triggering
it triggers intergenerational trauma of
residential schools it triggers family
conflict that comes from people like
teachers or principals or police anybody
in that position of authority who's an
adult so how do you as a researcher
going up into these regions who does not
have a relationship with
urban communities or those reserved
communities how do you ensure that
you're not just by being present there
triggering those individuals and those
community members you're absolutely
right I think in some respects the whole
education system has this as a challenge
that it is a trigger for for many of the
communities and there's a huge mistrust
of the education system there's a couple
of ways in which we're we're dealing
with this one as our primary
relationship with communities is through
the health sector not through the
educational sector because the health
sector has a much more credible and
positive relationship with the
communities the other thing is that we
would not walk I would not walk into a
community school myself and start trying
to talk to the youth when we're talking
with the youth it has been through the
teachers and engaging them taught so
with the hockey school it's not me going
in there this these are the coaches the
teachers the parents the volunteers and
we're working with them we have had
dialogue circles with youth it is not
usually me that goes it's with they
again a trusted individual in the
community the person who's running the
youth programs and my colleagues I'm I'm
the white woman my colleagues are First
Nations and they're the ones who are
often going in and working with youth
and they're trying to put things not in
terms of telling them what to do but
exploring within their own framework so
telling stories telling talking about
photographs talking about their own
experience but is it is it is the the
young First Nations members of our team
who are currently working directly with
youth
[Music]
you
[Music]